we've got some breaking news to bring
you from central london and that is that
the duke of edinburgh has been
transferred back to king
edward the seventh hospital for
continued treatment
let's go like our royal correspondent
and mills um and rihanna what is the
latest
so in the last few moments we have just
had a statement through from buckingham
palace in which they have said that
following the duke of edinburgh's
successful procedure
at st bartholomew's hospital on
wednesday his royal highness has now
been transferred to king edward the
seventh hospital
this morning they add that the duke is
expected to remain in hospital
for continuing treatment for a number
of days so just to recap it is now just
over
two and a half weeks since prince philip
first of all was admitted here to the
king edward the seventh hospital
where we were told that he was being
treated for an infection it was then
on monday much of the surprise to most
of us he was then transferred from king
edward vii
to two symbol bartholomew's hospital
and we were told that the reason that he
was being transferred was because he was
continuing his treatment
for that infection but also receiving
treatment and tests and observation for
a pre-existing
heart condition then yesterday it was
confirmed by the palace that the duke of
edinburgh had
undergone a successful procedure some
form of surgery for his heart
condition they wouldn't exactly confirm
what that treatment was
but they said that yesterday he was
expected to remain in hospital for a
number of days
then this morning at around 11 o'clock
our cameras which were outside saint
bart's hospital
saw an nhs ambulance leaving that
hospital
followed very closely by a vehicle that
would usually be used by the close
protection officers who are there to
protect members of the royal family
then later on i moved here to the king
edward the seventh hospital
and at around 12 o'clock we then saw
another
ambulance or the same ambulance actually
leaving
an exit from the king edward vii
hospital but it is in the last
few moments that it has now been
confirmed by the palace that yes the
duke of edinburgh has been moved
from some pathologies hospital where he
had that procedure for that heart
condition
and he is now back here at the king
edward the seventh